[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce nouveau à 7,8
sport l'émission est consacrée comme
vous le savez à l'actualité sportive
dans le département c'est parti à pour
le sommaire football en première
division de district les
clayes-sous-bois ont remporté le derby
contre montigny le bretonneux ce
dimanche
une victoire acquise dans les dernières
secondes qui permet au club de quitter
la dernière place du classement le
résumé dans ce magazine box tv 60,18
vous propose aujourd'hui de plongée dans
le quotidien de l'élan courtois a dit
lahm ou m'a dit le champion d'europe
s'entraînent chaque jour pour décrocher
une ceinture mondiale mais il a
également décidé de continuer en
parallèle son travail d'agent la ville
d'elancourt
reportage à suivre dans quelques
instants un solide coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur une discipline qui
recense de plus en plus d'adeptes en
france le sabre laser
des stages sont proposés à voisins le
bretonneux pour devenir le nouveau
maître jedi nous recevrons dans quelques
instants le fondateur cédric géraud
écoute projecteurs à présent sur les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football
direction les terrains de première
division de district un derby heavy noah
était programmé ce week-end les
clayes-sous-bois recevait montigny le
bretonneux pour une rencontre qui
sentait la poudre entre les deux
derniers du classement et c'est
finalement les clés siens qui longtemps
porté dans les dernières minutes 1 à 0
le résumé du match nicolas landry a pour
les images de l'engagement des
conditions climatiques difficiles et du
suspense ce dimanche au 10 décembre les
clayes-sous-bois qui évolue en bleus se
sont offert le derby vinoy contre
montigny le bretonneux sur l'adversaire
direct dans la course au maintien
indécis jusqu'à la 90e minute 7
rencontres de première division de
district s'est débloquée en faveur des
clés siens score final 1 0
dans les dix dernières minutes ça allait
vraiment d'un camp à l'autre on récupère
un ballon assez haut donc
une passe un peu verticale qui fait qu'
on est deux sur le même ballon et un
contrôle d un décalage en côte et une
troisième place devant le but mais est
obligé c'était juste le plat du pied ça
fait but
de son côté montigny le bretonneux
concède sa sixième défaite de la saison
la deuxième de l'année dans les arrêts
de jeu nous on a les occasions pour tuer
le match et puis larbi t'annonce deux
minutes on va
pense pouvoir au moins faire match nul
parce que c'est quand même avec un match
nul on aura été déçus et puis repart
avec zéro point au classement cette
deuxième victoire permet au promu cli
siens de passer devant son adversaire du
jour cellectis est le maintien
clairement c'est maintien en excellence
on arrive sur la pointe des pieds parce
que ça fait longtemps que le club avait
quitté cette division mais c'est de se
maintenir mais bon ça va être difficile
mais gare à ne pas céder et oies
cendrées après la trêve hivernale les
clayes-sous-bois reprendront le
championnat le 21 janvier 2018 contre
épaules de son côté montigny le
bretonneux jouera un match en retard
contre ou ce dimanche 17 décembre à
l'extérieur avant de penser aux vacances
on continue à parler de football fin de
l'épopée de voisins-le-bretonneux en
coupe gambardella la coupe de france des
moins de 19 ans après avoir atteint le
premier tour fédéral pour la première
fois de son histoire après son exploit
du tour précédent contre saint maur le
club yvelinois c'est finalement inclinés
4 buts 1 contre le fc ouest tour on joue
à l'extérieur résultat qui les condamne
à retourner au quotidien du championnat
encore un grand bravo aux quatorze
joueurs qui ont participé à cette
aventure hameau de la coupe de france à
présent et les hespérides sierra club de
ligue 1 ce sera finalement un club de
national une le petit poucet ou qui a
réussi à se hisser en 32e de finale de
la compétition affrontera concarneau les
yvelinois ne partira évidemment pas
favori de cette opposition cinq
divisions séparent les deux clubs mais
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
dans cette compétition en 2006 l'actuel
entraîneur douille franck blankenship
avait réussi à sortir avec son ancienne
formation du chéné l'équipe de sannois
saint gratien alors en national la
rencontre entre couilles et concarneau
devrait être programmée le week end du 6
janvier au stade maurice baquet à de la
ville on termine cette page football par
une information insolite le joueur du
paris saint germain à neymar était mardi
dernier en fin d'après-midi à elancourt
le footballeur n'est pas venu pour
signer dans le club local pour faire du
trampoline avec sa famille et ses amis
pendant deux heures dans le complexe au
john parkes d'elancourt ouvert il ya
tout juste un an
sur la photo on le voit avec les membres
de la structure on écoute justement la
réaction du jean christophe petit peu
plus grande surprise a été pour moi même
de l'accueillir effectivement
de le voir arriver tranquillement
voilà très bien très bonne très bonne
surprise chance à lui il arrivait après
les centres aérés à un moment où on
était j'irai dans une accalmie est quand
même là une accalmie c'est le cas pour
la petite histoire neymar n'a pas testé
les trampolines qualité légèrement
blessé et sûrement pour des questions à
d'assurance pour ce joueur qui a coûté
quand même 222 millions d'euros au paris
saint-germain du ballon rond on passe au
ballon ovale le sky rugby a réalisé une
belle performance ce week-end en
s'imposant à domicile contre brétigny
sur le score de 36 à 9
à l'occasion de la 8e journée du
championnat de division honneur
cette victoire leur permet de remonter à
la septième place du classement avec un
bilan de cinq victoires et trois
défaites depuis le début de la saison
dans le championnat de fédérale 2 après
avoir remporté une victoire importante
dans la course au maintien contre domont
la semaine dernière plaisir est retombé
dans ses travers l'équipe s'est inclinée
contre charte à l'extérieur sur le score
de 29 à 13 une défaite sans conséquence
pour le moment les plaisirs war est 10e
sur 12 avec six points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable
arras une fois n'est pas coutume nous
allons maintenant parler de tumbling
dans cette émission un sport dérivé de
la gymnastique
axel duriez 12 ans licenciés aux
clayes-sous-bois remporté en novembre la
médaille de bronze au championnat du
monde pour un par groupe d'âge à sofia
en bulgarie pour nous parler de cette
performance nous allons nous avons la
chance de recevoir sur ce plateau la
nouvelle star de la discipline
axel duriez ainsi que son coach rené et
ben ami bonsoir bonsoir
alors est ce que cette médaille de
bronze était attendu rené attendu espéré
parce que attendu c'est faut voir que
c'est le tout le gratin mondial qui se
retrouvent à cette compétition
le niveau est très relevé je n'ai jamais
eu de médaille internationale
de toute ma carrière avec les athlètes
donc je savais qu axel avait des grandes
capacités parce qu'il a fait une sortie
internationale donc de fin septembre et
octobre au portugal où il a raflé la
médaille d'or mais ce n'était qu'un
tournoi
tout le monde n'était pas là mais il y
avait déjà un petit indice s'était les
anglais qui sont une des meilleures
nations mondiales qui était présente et
donc il a battu ses angles de prises en
banque
je me suis dit une place en finale est
envisageable mais de là et encore les
russes ilya lien il ya d'autres
n'étaient pas présentes au tournoi donc
je me suis dit il ya encore les russes
donc je de là à dire j'ai fait un podium
non mais j'ai dit mais peut-être une
place en finale c'est déjà pas mal
j'ai un bon objectif est donc la
troisième place qu'il a décroché pour
moi c'était voilà c'était pas si attendu
que ça parce que le niveau est vraiment
très très très très relevée rapidement
le tome ligne pour quelqu'un qui
connaîtraient pas du tout ce sport à ce
qu'on nous présentait sa ce pari en
quelques mots je vous souhaite une sauce
sports acrobatiques ce qui se pratique
sur une piste qui l épidémie pistes
d'évolution qui est longue de 25 mètres
précédé d'une piste d'élan conférence m
et qui se termine par une piste de
réception qui fait si m donc le tumblr
c'est le nom approprié pour ce les
pratiquants du time line la tête avec
voilà ratings c'est ça doit traverser la
piste en exécutant huit figures
acrobatiques dont la dernière est
souvent la plus aérienne possible et
voilà et qui a noté en difficulté en
exécution dans son sport artistique
quand même comment tu t'es senti sur
cette compétition axel un peu stressé au
début sinon apprécié sais pas c'est quoi
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la différence
selon toi la propreté et bas après
j'aime y figure qui était quand même
ligne de mes meilleures figures à que je
savais faire
si je comprends bien la dernière figure
est peut-être la plus importante
axa oui on peut faire 2 2 fois la même
figure mais pas pas enchaîner dans
même du même imam figureront avant voilà
ton saut à l'écran est ce que tu es
satisfait ouvrez la réception c'est
important également dans le cas d'un
militant entre soi ce niveau là
justement c'est ce que j'allais dire
donc vous expliquer tout le monde
traverse avec décision d'appeler tempo
c'est ce qui sépare la prise d'élan la
dernière figure sa figure qui va faire
la différence
et à ce niveau là ils ont quasiment tous
plus ou moins la même difficulté et tout
se joue justement sur le petit pas se
dire qu'on peut descendre du podium
parce qu'on a fait un petit pas en trop
et donc c'est là où se joue en fait
c'était partage de premier deuxième
troisième et quatrième
c'est sur la réception le pas est très
important à la fin donc on travaille
énormément sur l'acrobatie mais aussi
sur la précision de la réception c'est
un truc sur lequel je n'aime pas de leur
répéter répéter la réception la
déception c'est celle à 5 la différence
en fait axel doit travailler sa
réception justement huit ans qu'on va
travailler parce que la preuve il n'a
pas ce qu'on appelle piles et ça veut
dire pile est à dire arriver sans aucun
mouvement
il a fait un pas donc faut qu'on a
travaillé je pense le club d'acte est
souvent considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs clubs de france où l'on peut
dire pour le timing on peut le dire nous
offrait un cadre idéal on peut le dire
pour pour les jeunes malheureusement
c'est pas un cadre idéal dans le sens où
au niveau structure nos peines à
l'équipe et c'est à dire que tous les
jours les jeunes chômeurs comme axel
montus matériel qui est assez conséquent
est lourd mais par contre en terme de
compétences techniques d'entraîneur de
du 2
donc comité directeur du club qui est
hyper présent de d'investissement
financier du club qui nous envoie en
stage à l'étranger
là dessus le confort le coup le confort
est présent le seul bémol kaunas et
qu'on n'a pas là la structure idéale
ça veut dire une salle spécialisée pour
le tumbling c'est le seul bémol mais
tout ce qui tout le reste on n'est pas
se plaindre
axel vous avez été formé du coup au club
des clayes-sous-bois est ce que vous
comptez y rester encore longtemps
attention il ya le coach qui est enfin
bah oui ce serait même j'aimerais bien
entraîner hqe les bleus entraînés
prendre la place de rené famy dans
quelques années
alors vous avez vous 20 ans de carrière
derrière vous a fait vous avez formé de
nombreux jeunes vous avez emmené des
jeunes en équipe de france également skc
axel à sa place parmi les plus grands
que vous ayez entraîner oui mais toute
façon
sans dénigrer le travail de parce que
s'ils regardent vont dire mais comment
tu parle de nous je pense que oui axel à
quelque chose de plus que les autres
c'est à dire bon quelque chose de plus
aux six mois peut-être un entraîneur
plus aguerris aussi ça veut dire que des
années passent et je vais encore avec
accepte quand tu à m'améliorer j'ai
entendu tellement de choses à apprendre
pour arriver d'un lieu au petit trot
suprême peut-être un jour donc oui j'ai
beaucoup de très bons taux de l'heure
dans le club on l'a juline à plusieurs
de ses grands de ses aînés qui ont fait
des catholiques de france juniors
seniors y en a un c'est pas de julien
couderc a fait deux médailles de bronze
1 eindhoven aux pays bas en 2005 par
équipe et c'est des jeunes aussi qui ont
été au pôle de formation c'est à dire
qu'un pôle qui s'appelle le pôle de
formation de rennes qui accueille les
les meilleurs tomes l'heure pour non
troppo là pour leur proposer une
meilleure un meilleur environnement pour
adéquate à la pratique du sport de haut
niveau axel duriez a donc douze ans il a
quatre titres consécutifs de champion de
france depuis 2014
la médaille d'or au tournoi
international de l'oulle en 2012 ou en
est-ce qu'il peut tout simplement encore
s'améliorer à 12 ans est-ce qu'il a
encore une grande marge de progression
je suis quelqu'un qui rêve beaucoup et
pour moi c'est bien sûr et sa médaille
de bronze on a tellement fait t on l'a
tellement j'ai tellement félicité mais
faut il sait très bien les comme moi je
pense que lui aussi ses seins
c'est un gagnant il a envie de pour lui
encore deux marches à gravir et donc par
la suite est-ce qui va chercher il a
cherché à avoir cette médaille d'or
voilà c'est là il pourra dire j'ai
atteint mon objectif
et puis peut-être c'est puissant
seigneur parce que là les séparent cassé
par groupes d'âge et mais le titre
suprême sur la cantine et qu'on tenait
en seniors et donc je pense que c'est un
de ses rêves
donc je le laisserais vie donc je pense
que c'est justement la médaille là
autour du coup tu veux tu peux nous l'a
montré
voilà deux médailles d'or bientôt c'est
un objectif tempur en rêve
ouais bah serait d'être champion du
monde champion du monde
je pense que ça peut arriver rapidement
pas rapidement rappelé on va travailler
pour alors beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup d'entraînement dans les
prochains mois merci à tous les deux
dépassé sur ce plateau vous souhaite
évidemment de remporter l'or dans les
prochaines années
et voilà une fin de saison en apothéose
on peut le dire rapidement la fin donc
je aussi à féliciter mon équipe de mon
équipe ou de landes championnat de
france en dix ans division nationale
d'huile
on l'a fini médailles d'or dont le
champion de france donc voilà je fais un
petit clin d'oeil à cette équipe là qui
ne sont pas présents mais je pense que
le message est passé
merci beaucoup nous allons à présent
parler d'une autre performance à couper
le souffle celle d'andy cabreira avila
s'offrant concubin de 46 ans réussit à
repousser encore un peu plus les limites
du corps humain pendant ce week-end du
téléthon dans la piscine aqua mundo de
saint-cyr-l'ecole maître nageur a
réalisé 53,3 150 km en faisant des
longueur en apnée pendant 24 heures elle
a pulvérisé le record de près de 17 km
pour réussir cet exploit l'apnéiste n'a
pas dormi pendant toute la durée de la
performance le champion on nous explique
les difficultés qu'il a rencontrées au
micro de tv 78 c'est des petits crabes
qui vient et qui ont douanes fait
attention à l'intensité et la nage
parce qu'ici en club arrive après on
s'arrêter donc ça ralentit donc c'est
pour chacun d'eux
en fait tous les vingt longueurs
maintenant une minute deux minutes ça
répond le temps des nations des nages et
je m'hydrate avec des lots à 8 de l'or
et des choux haarde et celle des
datations alive et haribo de bicarbonate
il faut hydrater tout le temps de temps
son record pourrait être enregistrée au
guinness book des records sa performance
a permis de récolter plus de 1000 euros
en faveur du téléthon
un mot de boxe à présent il est sans
contexte conteste l'un des yvelinois à
de l'année a dit lahm ou mady a conservé
sa ceinture européenne de boxe le 11
novembre dernier au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avant de se
tourner vers le championnat du monde le
sportif s'adonne à une autre carrière
celle d'agents de la ville d'elancourt
avantage de et xavier jamais il y a le
boxeur mais aussi l'animateur deux
facettes qui constitue a dit la môme a
dit l'athlète vous le connaissez sans
doute champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens ceinture que l'élan
courtois a conservé en battant
christopher est brassée à l'issue des 12
rounds c'était à domicile lors du maine
et 24 ou vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et encore
merci pour ceux qui me soutiennent une
ceinture européenne conquise pour la
première fois en 2015 face à l'espanyol
mariano hilario adila à mohammadia alors
34 ans succès obtenu sur le tard certes
mais le boxeur vise toujours plus haut
qui a fait la peut-être la différence
sur ce combat c'était peut-être la
détermination
voilà je sais pourquoi j'y suis allé je
voulais cette ceinture c'est un objectif
que je voulais atteindre de la
détermination il en a fallu aux sportifs
un an plus tard nous sommes en 2016
adila mohammadi remet en jeu son titre
face à l'anglais kaloum smith à
liverpool
un combat qui tourne mal dès le premier
round libinois tente sa chance mais vite
dépassé par son adversaire et l'arbitré
contraint d'arrêter le match
après cette défaite me dit alors le
boxeur fini c'est mal le connaître
adila se remet vite en selle avec l'aide
de la team farrugia et du promoteur
malamine koné n'ont alors ma carrière
n'est pas terminée
il faut le savoir n'est pas terminé ma
carrière je suis pas un rêveur voilà
rêver c'est quand on dort nord ont fait
pas grand chose donc moi je suis
vraiment plus qu'elle tient qui a qui a
des objectifs
voilà et mon but c'est de les atteindre
au printemps dernier le compétiteur au
conquiert déjà sa ceinture européenne
d'un an après l'avoir perdue et concerne
donc son titre en novembre face à
christopher rebrassé à 37 ans a dit la
môme a dit se laisse encore du temps
pour être challenger d'une ceinture
mondiale
en attendant quand il n'est pas à
l'entraînement ou sur les rings a dit la
môme a dit consacrent du temps à son
autre vie celle d'agents de la ville
d'elancourt un travail auprès des
enfants de l'école
willy brandt comme ce jour là avec des
activités organisées au complexe sportif
de l'europe
hélas de la boxe semble se muer
parfaitement dans la peau d'animateur
c'est un animateur
il travaille bien il me fait rigoler les
gens de surfer début moi je pensais que
c'était un simple animateur et comme mes
pas m'ont dit quand il est passé à la
télé ça m'a surpris un grand boxeur et
il est très gentil directeur de centre
de loisirs à son arrivée et l'encours a
dit là est re devenu ensuite animateurs
avec des échéances sportives de plus en
plus importante
il doit composer avec un emploi du temps
très chargé mais effectue tout de même
un service de 35 heures par semaine pour
la mairie yvelinoise ceci une coupure
une coupure par rapport à à ce que je
peux faire le soir j'ai notre vie aussi
bon set cette petite différence le
boxeur finalement qui n'est pas si brut
que sa vie qui finalement il est il et
il est avec les enfants aussi rapports
humains qui et qui fait que ça me plait
quoi a dit la môme hâtive à rentrer très
prochainement dans une nouvelle phase de
préparation travailler dur pour
atteindre son prochain objectif monter
sur le toit du monde
un autre boxeur de la team farruggia
sera sur les rings en 2018 l'élan
courtois à marvin petit que vous voyez
en ce moment à l'écran devrait défendre
sa ceinture de l'union européenne le 20
janvier au palais des sports marcel
cerdan de levallois perret dans une
soirée de gala organisée par malamine
koné son adversaire n'est pas n'a pas
encore été dévoilée marvin petit n'a
connu qu'une seule défaite dans sa
carrière pour 22 succès et un nul
il vise un championnat du monde dans
l'est à deux ans on ouvre à présent une
page un solide dans ce set 8 sport c'est
l'un des films les plus attendus de
l'année star wars épisode 8 sortira dans
les salles obscures ce mercredi en
france
on y verra a sans doute des combats au
sabre laser
une discipline qui a dépassé à la
fiction pour venir s'implanter dans les
yvelines en 2016 une académie a vu le
jour à voisins le bretonneux et propose
des cours d'initiation pour manier cette
arme comme dark vador ou luke skywalker
pour nous parler de ce sabre laser de
ces cours de sabre laser nous recevons
sur ce plateau
cédric cédric conquet c'est pourquoi
vous avez voulu créer cette académie des
sabres laser à voisins bretons mais bon
c'était un concours de circonstance avec
effectivement une discussion avec des
amis et comme ça arrive est en fait
assez rapidement sur le sur le
territoire français les académies de
sabre laser existait depuis nombreuses
années mais plutôt au niveau combats
chorégraphiés et là il y avait le combat
sportif
une qui commence à se mettre en place au
niveau du sabre laser donc nous on a
voulu au niveau de l'académie faire
quelque chose de bain 2
très structuré surtout parce que comme
c'est un conte un sport à la touche
on voulait vraiment que les gens soient
en sécurité puissent pratiquer avec un
cadre très très stricte pour pâques et
d'accidents au niveau de la compétition
et puis surtout pour offrir aux gens à
la vraie possibilité de pratiquer le
sabre laser comme un art martial
c'est sûr première vous encadrez
complètement cette pratique c'est ça
l'académie nous on est basée en fait à
voisins le bretonneux on a d'autres
clubs qui sont à triel sur seine
également donc nous aussi dans les
yvelines et on a d'autres académies qui
s'ouvre avoir affronté vicomte dans
l'essonne on en a une autre si du côté
de belfort et on travaille tous en fête
sur la mule système qui est une académie
américaine il s'appelle terra prime donc
en fait taire à primes existent depuis
2012 aux etats-unis c'est la seule
académique a vraiment développé un
programme très structuré en lien avec
l'univers forcément et qui permet aux
gens de progresser et d'avoir une vraie
pratique sportive et martial du sabre
laser ça fait bien donc des états unis
si je comprends bien oui c'est ça la
plupart des académies les plus anciennes
academy viennent c'est un petit peu
normal aussi un des des états-unis et lé
avantage d'avoir travaillé avec cette
académie là c'est que du coup on a pu
avoir une référence en france assez
intéressante et la fédération française
d'escrimé nous a demandés en fait
d'intégrer un groupe de travail parce
que le sabre laser est maintenant
intégré depuis janvier dernier en tant
qu'arme attend la fédération au niveau
de ses statuts donc pour le moment c'est
que du combat chorégraphié ingrédients
mais là il ya actuellement un groupe de
travail qui penche sur le fait de
pouvoir vraiment avoir une vraie
discipline de sport à la touche avec le
sabre laser très encadré et la première
chose qu'il faut faire c'est ma
référence et le matériel que vous voyez
devant vous donc à les sabres laser mais
il ya aussi les protections qui vont
avec
je savoir deux sabres il fonctionne
comment alors le sabre
on a des références à ces trois modèles
ici donc là on a un fabricant français
qui s'appelaient les gones crippen ce
qu'ils fabriquent des sabres pour les
enfants donc là on a un sabre qui est
composé en fait d'une led qui a alimenté
par une pile en général c'est un accu
genre à cul de cigarettes électroniques
j'ai pas de publicité avec un
interrupteur donc ça ce sont les modèles
les plus simples on a les modèles
adultes donc la lame est plus longue et
le manche aussi également donc là et
rouge par contre cela et rouges
jouissent et le mien c'est pour ça donc
on a une lame en polycarbonate la même
polycarbonate elle est assez épaisse
très résistante plus résistance qu'un os
humains donc forcément quand on fait un
sport à la touche mais il faut avoir des
protections adaptées et dans la dernière
catégorie on a aussi des sabres
attention les yeux et les oreilles on a
des sabres avec du fond qui permet aussi
des changements de couleur avec un
accéléromètre qui permet aussi dé sont
dit on n'est plus dans le gadget ou dans
la vraie arme notre marine et dans la
vraiment en fait
à la différence de ce qu'on pourrait
trouver dans le commerce au grand public
ça ce sont vraiment des des armes de
combat
c'est à dire que les larmes en
polycarbonate s'entrechoquer les les
les poignées sont en aluminium donc tout
ça est très résistant et permet encore
une fois de pouvoir pratiquer un sport
la touche on a des protections pour le
moment qu'ils sont en train d'être
testée et pouvoir avoir un dossier
technique au niveau de l'assureur de la
fédération française d'escrimé pour que
le lait compétition au sabre laser
puisse vraiment se mettre en place il ya
combien d'adeptes pour l'instant à
voisins bretons 9 alors nous club on est
une trentaine en sachant qu'on a huit
enfants de 8 à 10 en a
douze ou quatorze enfants entre 11 et 14
et après à partir de 15 ans les prendre
à la section adulte et sur triel on est
aussi à peu près une quinzaine de
pratiquants
surfant telle vicomte ils sont une
dizaine donc on va avoir un groupe qui
va compter on va dire bien une
cinquantaine de personnes sans compter
bien sûr tous les autres clubs 1 qui
pratique aussi le combat au sabre laser
en france
dernière question est-ce qu'il faut
absolument être fan de star wars pour
commencer à cette discipline non encore
on a des groupes très très différent il
ya des fans forcément c'est à la
majorité mais il ya des gens qui veulent
découvrir une nouvelle discipline
sportive ludique qui amène des choses un
petit peu de nouvelles
là on voit un sabre laser mais dans la
pratique du sabre laser on peut
travailler à deux sabres laser un double
sabre laser la pratique elle est assez
vaste
elle encadre également des styles de
combat différent originalement c'était
le cadeau que tels que george lucas
l'avait l'avait imaginé dans leur star
wars mais on trouve aussi de l'escrim
plutôt européenne du chambard à la canne
de combat du kung fu donc c'est très
très grasse au niveau de la pratique
vous allez voir les derniers sawers qui
va sortir mercredi on sera lui c'est à
lui et dernier cas on sera à l'ugc
cyrano mercredi pour faire des
démonstrations et forcément le soir
ferrals film également merci à vous
c'est vrai que j'y revienne mais on vous
souhaite d'avoir de plus en plus
d'adeptes mais votre discipline à voisin
bretonneux deux rendez vous à noter dans
vos agendas roller hockey les chocs
d'elancourt reçoit ce dimanche le 17
décembre à 11h30 les fossoyeurs de fos
au gymnase chastagner les élans courtois
ne seront pas favoris de la rencontre
actuellement cinquièmes ils affrontent
le deuxième qui n'a perdu que deux
rencontres depuis le début de la saison
si vous voulez les supporter l'entrée
est libre et puis un rendez-vous basket
à ne pas manquer les féminines du
chesnay versailles se déplace ce
week-end sur le terrain de wasquehal
pour le compte de la 11e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 les
yvelinoises doivent l'emporter pour
terminer la phase aller dans les cinq
premiers du classement
l'objectif annoncé en début de saison
les versaillaise sont pour le moment 7e
à quatre points du leader sainte savine
des images insolites pour refermer ce
magazine des vélocipèdes les
ancêtre du vélo ont déambulé ce dimanche
dans les rues de versailles 21
participants ont voulu recréer la toute
première course cycliste mondial qui
s'est tenu entre paris la cité royale le
8 décembre 1867 pour cette réédition les
cyclistes ont mis près de quatre heures
trente pour boucler les 17 km soit trois
heures de plus que les pros trois
premiers de 1867
on écoute l'un des participants l'ancien
journaliste sportif gérard holtz il nous
explique le fonctionnement de ces vélos
dans l'autre tente on se propulse donc
en appuyant sur les pédales à l'avant
ici est le problème
regardez le problème et voilà pour la
précision de la conduite
la difficulté c'est ça faut pas mettre
la roue dans les trous et puis le frein
très important le frein c'est juste une
petite corde on tourner le guidon comme
ça pour tirer sur la corde et le patin
ici fresnes et bloquent la roue de temps
voilà ça bloque la revoilà voilà le
principe c'est la fin de six sept huit
sports merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]